Ted Cruz he is sort of started this
whole government shutdown thing because
he hates Obamacare did his 21 hour
filibuster that actually wasn't a
filibuster sort of because it was
against a Republican House bill and he's
a Republican in the Senate okay blah
blah blah did you know he is backed by a
pot-smoking gay billionaire yeah that's
right Peter teal who is the founder of
PayPal he was also one of the first
investors in Facebook he has given a ton
of money to Ted Cruz actually I have a
number here he gave two million dollars
to the Club for Growth which is not a
Hair Club I thought it was on first look
that's a super PAC that then gave over
six hundred thousand dollars to Ted
Cruz's election campaign in Texas now
some of the other things that Peter
Thiel has given money to include space
travel life extension anti aging
artificial intelligence and he even gave
a hundred thousand dollars to twenty
kids not to go to college just to see
what would happen with their life so
he's into some pretty progressive
scientific things which all seem very
reverse of what Ted Cruz believes what
do we make of this and how much can we
get out of that someone gives someone
money can be really glean everything
into them can you figure really figure
it out about them yeah I mean this one's
a little bit of an easy bouncing ball to
follow here Peter Thiel is a staunch
libertarian yeah he's all about you know
the extreme measures of people being
able to do whatever they want as long as
everything is privatized Ted Cruz has to
appeal to his more conservative
constituents however he also is a kind
of you know very strict
constitutionalist according to what Ted
Cruz is saying right now at least he's
coming out swinging like Constitution
Constitution it's one of his favorite
words well that's in line with what
Peter teal is in line with so even
though you wouldn't think that maybe on
a social scene that they would match up
at least for what Peter teals immediate
goals are for his finances and where he
wants his super back to go and the Club
for Growth is heavy heavy libertarian
stuff he sees that Ted Cruz is kind of
the person who's an up-and-coming
loudmouth type of person that would
champion him now it's interesting as Ted
Cruz has kind of been distancing himself
from Peter Thiel in certain circles you
know gosh well you know the gayness and
the pot smoking and basically these
things that are central to probably
things in his daily life and that makes
up Who I am has nothing to do with all
this money in the fact that he loves the
private sector he loves the constitution
too right okay what could ted cruz hate
more than gayness and pot-smoking can
you even think of I guess Obama it would
be interesting and it would be a real
opportunity for Ted Cruz which
unfortunately I doubt he's I don't think
he'll take it
but if Ted Cruz we really wanted to come
out and be a leader in his party what he
would say is look this person's values
are in line with mine he is gay he you
know smokes marijuana but his values are
in line with mine that he wants less
government that he wants less people up
in our business or whatever you know the
Tea Party is obsessed with and actually
turn the party around and say we can
have people that don't look like I sound
like us you know and to have the same
social values on our side and he could
turn the whole party right so Rick
before I let you jump in so these other
things like space travel that is
something that Ted Cruz is not big on
funding I assure you I actually can't
swear to an effect but life extension
anti-aging artificial entities are all
the type of things that get cut from
budgets because they're based in science
deals just putting the hip and hypocrisy
yeah that's all he wants cuz with you
know he's hoping no one puts this level
of analysis into the issue yeah I hope
that whatever they hear about the story
they'll assume it's a lie and they'll go
right back to whatever their world look
like right before they heard this news
they had waste a lock truth out they
figured out how to do it yeah so I think
that this is in line with what Peter
Chill wants Peter Thiel is a strict
constitutionalist and libertarian so he
believes that he should be with his
private Mundy money funding space travel
funding all these things so Ted Cruz
again would get on board with him by
saying the government shouldn't be
funding all these experiments and all
these unnecessary things this should
come from the private sector so you
could profit on it once you know they
are very much in line this this
relationship makes a lot of sense yeah
again if they could just come around and
say we don't care if you're gay and you
smoke weed you have all the same values
assets yeah so in a weird way so they're
they're sort of like an unholy alliance
but it in a bizarre way it's sort of
based in things that they seem to
believe so it's actually is something
like this okay can for example just
going with the gay thing is it okay for
someone who is gay who I assume believes
in equality to go
and back someone who doesn't believe in
that or is that an overriding issue
related to all the others I think our
standards were okay and theirs are two
entirely different planets yeah what we
call okay it's not even on their radar
you know and what they call okay there's
just different things that they want and
the shield's they'll put up and a lot of
these things they're just you know a
layman to be Christian is often just a
safe house for a creepy dude there's
goes now you've got to go for that nine
miles of concrete I just put between us
yeah and I'm just I'm safer here longer
is all it is you know and I think a lot
of what they're saying into the camera
is we have a seems like the mainstream
news has a tendency to ask a liar if
they're a liar which is the definition
of insanity you know I don't think I
don't think they mean most of what they
say yeah on the air I think they just
want us the their followers to believe
they mean if they want their followers
to be antithetical to them in many ways
as long as it serves them on the yard
that's a dog you want outside but not in
the house yeah so so what's the deal
with libertarians and the gay issue
because to me a true libertarian who
believes in liberty and limited
government and that you should believe
in what you believe and own your body in
your mind should they should be Rand
Paul and Ted Cruz by the definition of
what they're supposed to believe in
should believe in in marriage equality
and that and that yeah I think that they
are in this world so I covered the LMC I
covered the libertarian National
Convention and there were more very open
transvestites transsexual people and
with extreme you know different social
things that they were into there at the
LNC because they wanted to be part of it
and they were excited about last year's
candidate was the governor Gary Johnson
from Mexico I've interviewed him he's
extremely socially liberal but extremely
fiscally conservative which i think is
weirdly in line again with what the Tea
Party wants and the Tea Party is just
this weird super right faction of Kooks
that they're so right-wing that they
forget that what they really want can
only be accomplished by privatizing and
leaving people that F alone yeah so when
they forget that leaving you alone is
really what they want your that means
your bedroom too not just your finances
not just your healthcare not whatever
they think they want not touched by the
government that means that government
leaves
nothing alone no marriage amendments
blocking marriage that means people can
do what they want but libertarians
cherry-pick how do they do how do they
cherry pick that that's what I'm trying
to figure out here how do they decide
that they get so that's purely when it
shifts from week to week is they get a
new memo oh now this groups mad they're
like the guy on the Sullivan Show been
in this place but now these guys are mad
over here over here but now this one is
wobbling I gotta run back there that's
why they all are drunk they all look
like they're falling apart
they're doing this fado room-to-room
runaround farce trying to hold a lie
together yeah and and the one thing they
didn't want was the internet starting to
get the truth out and it was starting to
show TV shows that would have the truth
and people publishing the truth and it's
disintegrating their little bubble that
was there wasn't supposed to be that
other data out there was only supposed
to be our version of the BS out there
yeah that's falling about we're watching
that part fall apart this is like the
Martian walkers in War of the Worlds and
they look like they're gonna fight but
now this liquid squeak and they're
falling all over the place now you could
knock them over
they're disintegrated by their own
[ __ ] basic yeah all right well there
are no spinning plates here I promise
you because I don't have to hey guys the
Reuben report is brought to you by
Cooper comm they've got 75% off dog and
cat chews toys accessories home goods
and more use code RR for 20% off your
next purchase the link is right down
there